- Welcome back, we have here
Kevin James and Renata Notni.
Our next guest not only
played a talented singer
and songwriter on the hit show Nashville,
he is one in real life as well.
His debut solo album is
called Love Ain't Pretty.
It's available now wherever
you get your music.
So check it out, everybody say hello
to friend of the show Charles Esten.
(audience cheers)
(upbeat rock music)
All right, so they gave me extra,
'cause we love Charles.
- Thanks for the extra.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah. (laughs)
I didn't know this about
you, but you start,
and I feel like I've known you for a bit,
but like you started on Broadway.
I didn't--
- I started on Broadway.
- I didn't finish it. (laughs)
- I know, but I didn't know that.
- Well, yeah I mean, I love that what you,
New York suits you.
- I love New York.
- Well I can tell that, Kelly.
- Yeah.
- It comes right through the screen and it
suited me for a quick minute.
I was in Los Angeles and auditioned
for the show called Smokey Joe's Cafe.
It was a revue of the songs
of Leiber and Stoller.
So great, really--
- I performed that.
- In pop choir in high school.
- You did?
- Yeah.
- Well, years before that I
auditioned for the Broadway show
and I just had a really great audition.
For years before that, I
would get a vocal audition
for a Broadway show and they'd go,
all right, they wanna see a callback.
And I go, for what?
And they say, oh, they,
it's a dance audition.
I go, well, I don't dance,
so I probably shouldn't go do that.
- Yeah, just show up
and lie and say you can.
- No, that's what they said.
They just wanna see if you can move.
And apparently I can't move.
But anyway, this one audition,
I just was free and loose.
I did a couple Elvis songs.
Hound Dog, Leiber and Stoller
wrote Hound Dog and Jailhouse Rock.
- Yeah.
- And so I think I bamboozled them.
And then I went here on Broadway
and we were rehearsing
in the studios downtown.
And I looked around and I
was surrounded by people
that were just legit Broadway talent.
My leading lady was DeLee
Lively and she was unbelievable.
Such a great dancer, singer.
And then I think it was
about three weeks in,
the director finally showed
up to see where we were.
And I could just see on
his face, him watching me.
You know that thing where you
have like imposter syndrome
and you're like, I don't belong here.
And everybody's gonna figure that out.
- Still have it.
- I have that often.
- Well, they figured it out. (laughs)
He looked at me and he
said in front of everybody,
he stopped the whole thing.
He goes, "Let me ask you
a question: Do you dance?"
And I said, "Well Jerry,
that falls under things
"you should have asked at the audition."
(all laugh)
And, and I said, I'm doing my best.
I will get it by showtime,
I promise you that.
About a week later, he gave
me a very nice phone call
and he said, we really
appreciate your hard work,
but we're gonna have to--
- Aw.
- [Charles] So they recast the role.
- Oh.
- And the first thing I found
out was that I had a contract.
So I got paid for a year,
for not being in that show.
- Well that's great.
- That's like the one time
- Amazing.
- you're thankful for contracts.
- It was unbelievable.
- That's amazing.
I'm at six months in, I go to my mailbox,
I'm like, honey, I got a raise.
I gotta bump at six months.
So, and another thing I found out is,
if I had done that show, I
would not have been available
to get on Whose Line is it Anyway?
- Oh I love that.
- Which changed my life,
- being on that show
for a number of years.
And then a final couple, two things.
Years later, six or eight years later,
we're walking some fair in LA,
and we see DeLee Lively and her husband,
who was the guy they replaced me with.
- Oh.
- Aw.
- All these things had to happen.
- They had three kids.
They had one in her arm,
one in the stroller,
one walking, and they were amazing.
And we talked and it was really,
and I go, I think it's very important
that you guys understand and know
and remember that you have all this bliss.
You have this paradise
because Charles Esten
can't dance.
- Can't dance.
(all laugh)
(audience applauds)
- You're welcome.
So this is your first solo album.
So are you excited about
that or nervous about that?
- I'm really excited.
You know, by the time it's out,
you got, you just want to get it out.
I put out a ton of singles over the years.
- That's all me, yeah.
- When, you know, when
I went to Nashville,
it really opened music
all the way open again.
Like it used, it was a door
that I sort of stepped away from it.
It was what I did first in college.
I was in a band and all this thing.
But I ended up doing the
acting and that drew me away.
I would improvise songs on
Whose Line or things like that.
But, so from then I started
putting out a bunch of singles.
I think I've always held the
album as something special,
'cause I grew up with albums that--
- Actual stories.
- You know.
- Like the whole, yeah.
- They meant something.
- Like when when you'd listen on the radio
and you'd hear a song and
you immediately knew the song
that followed it on the album.
- That's right.
- Yeah.
- You could hear it coming
or you knew a little bit.
And so albums like Born to Run,
where it was like a movie to me,
and here comes Meeting Across the River,
and Jungle Land and all these things.
So I sort of held the
album in such high regard
that I wanted to take some time.
I wanted to figure out
who I am as an artist.
You knew that instantly.
I'm so you just, your voice.
- You know what, I didn't.
- You didn't?
- No, 'cause you know why?
I love everything.
I love every kind of music,
so that's the hard thing about me.
- So you could sing like
the other great singers
and you had to slowly not sing like them?
- Well I just mean like
finding your own sound.
Like when someone says,
what is your sound?
I'm like, I don't know.
Like I don't, you know, I guess pop.
What's popular.
- That's crazy to me.
- Because I would, I
would think you would,
it seems to me you know,
but I'm the same way.
Like I've sung like so many other people.
I started off playing Buddy
Holly in the West End.
And on Whose Line you'd be singing a song
like Sting, or Bono, or
Neil Young or whatever.
So by the time I got to Nashville
I was trying to figure out
who I am, what I wanted to say.
- I think that's always evolving as well.
- Yeah. That's it.
- 'Cause it's your--
- Who you're inspired by as well, yeah.
Do you remember like your first, like,
I don't know, your first
concert you ever went to,
your first time you were inspired
by an actor that made you wanna act?
- Yeah, I mean, I watched,
you know, standup specials.
Robert Klein was a comedian that you know,
and when you start doing
standup, you kind of start
doing, taking on their
cadence and stuff like that.
Until you kind of
find yourself.
- Yeah, we're all imitators
- Exactly.
- Until you find yourself.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So that was, yeah, for sure.
- Okay, everybody, Charles is performing
for us later so stick around.
It's so good.
All the lines are good in it.
It's like very well written.
And up next it's a story that's
very personal for Charles.
We're gonna meet an incredibly brave kid
who fought cancer and won.
Yes. (applauds)
(audience applauds)
Now she's helping other kids do the same.
We'll be right back.
- Years ago Charles went through an ordeal
that no parent wants to experience.
At two and a half years old,
his daughter was diagnosed with leukemia.
Thankfully she got through it,
and today she is cancer free. (applauds)
(audience applauds)
But Charles knows how
difficult that rollercoaster
is for any kid and for their family.
That's why he wanted
to meet our next guest.
She too is a childhood
cancer survivor. (applauds)
(audience applauds)
She's also the founder of a huge nonprofit
that helps kids and their families
worldwide cope as they battle cancer.
At age 15 she is one of our
youngest Rad Humans ever.
(upbeat rock music)
(audience applauds)
Alright, y'all from the Koenig
Childhood Cancer Foundation,
please welcome Elana.
(audience applauds)
Meet Charles.
- Hello, Elana.
- Oh my God.
- It's nice to meet you.
- It's so nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you too.
- I'm such a big fan.
- Oh, that's so sweet.
Thank you so much.
She's a fan of Jesse
on the Disney Channel.
- Oh I love it!
- I played the dad on Jesse.
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- That's amazing. I forget that part.
I forget that.
- Yeah, I know.
- It was such a long time ago.
- It's, yeah, it was.
You were just a little kid then, right?
- I know.
- You're so old and wise now.
So how old were you
when you were diagnosed?
- Yeah, so I was actually diagnosed right
before my eighth birthday in 2016.
It was such a stressful time.
My mom was sort of the
first one who realized
that something was wrong with
me because I was limping.
She brought me to the
hospital immediately.
She rushed me to get help.
I obviously, I didn't wanna go,
because hospitals are
scary for kids my age.
But when I got the diagnosis,
everything sort of changed after that.
I had to live in the hospital
for one and a half years.
I had nine cycles of chemo, 15 surgeries.
It was the most significant
time of my life.
I can't even express
how much it affected me.
But luckily I'm six years
cancer free right now.
(audience applauds)
- I can't, it's hard on you
and it's hard on your family.
I imagine that your family,
like what y'all went through
and your daughter was diagnosed like that.
- Absolutely. Yeah.
- You, you were in and
out right, of hospitals?
- Well, when I hear her
tell the story, it's,
our daughter was two and a
half when Addie was diagnosed
and she had about two years
of chemotherapy herself.
There she is.
And so, but I've always thought
it was an incredible blessing
that she was so young
that she didn't really
understand any of it.
So it was like a new
day and she didn't know
she was gonna be losing her hair.
She didn't know that she had
a spinal tap the next day.
And that was a real
blessing when I see kids
who are a little bit older,
- They're aware.
- that Elana was old enough to understand
so much of what was going on.
So it always blows my mind.
But I always find again and again,
when I meet these kids that
have been through this,
that they, you can already
tell she's different.
She has this strength,
she has this charisma,
this power and intelligence.
So I'm not surprised at all.
- Yeah.
Explain the foundation to everybody.
- Yeah, so I'd like to think
that I turned my pain into an opportunity.
I started it in 2020 with
the support of my family.
I couldn't have done it without them.
I wanted to help the kids in the hospital
who I had connected with
during my treatment.
It started with that with
only $900 in my piggy bank.
But then it sort of--
- That's a pretty good piggy bank.
(all laugh)
I don't know my piggy bank ever made that.
I bought too much music, yeah.
- I know, after that it grew
into a $1.5 million charity.
- Geez.
- Yeah.
We help kids financially, emotionally.
We have gift bags that we
deliver to the hospital,
that we put items in based
off of what I went through.
We have socks, squishies, handmade cards,
brochures if they wanna register for help.
We pay for medical bills.
We've helped over 30,000
families worldwide.
We've delivered 3,500 goodie bags.
We've had 2,500
celebrations and visits
with kids in the hospital.
I'd like to think that
all we do is for the kids.
Especially knowing how far
I've grown since I beat cancer.
- Yeah, you beat it.
I love saying it like that too.
Yeah. Yeah.
So you, you, I don't know,
you got your message out in
a very creative way, I feel.
Like you were singing the
national anthem, right?
How did that idea come about?
- Yeah, so I have been connected
with music long before I was diagnosed.
I've been taking singing classes
since I was six years old.
- Yeah.
- I sang to other kids in the hospital.
I sang in talent shows.
I'd like to think it,
you know, soothed them.
It helped them as well as it helped me.
So after I started my
foundation I you know,
got opportunities like the Mets game
which was very exciting.
That was a vital moment
in sharing my experience,
sharing my message, the cause.
And since then I've been using my voice
to help kids in the hospital.
- Yeah, well I know that Charles,
you wanna say something to Elana, right?
- Well, absolutely.
First of all, I think
sometimes you meet people
and you go, this is somebody
where cancer messed with the wrong person.
Because you're coming back
and fighting it on
behalf of so many others.
Because of our daughter
Addie, my wife Patty
and I started years ago,
a thing called Team Addie.
And we raised money for the Leukemia
and Lymphoma Society with Team Addie.
And my question to you is,
have you been to Nashville before?
Have you been to Music City?
- I have not.
- Well, I was wondering if we
could fly you to Music City
and you could be a part of
our next benefit concert.
Would you do that?
(audience applauds)
Oh, hey.
Please say yes.
Aw, sweetheart.
- I love it.
- Thank you, love.
- We appreciate that.
We thank you so much.
- You're gonna love it.
If you like music, and I think people
always think when Nashville
they just think country music,
which it is obviously very
much a core part of that city.
But everybody's there.
Like rock and roll people,
singer/songwriters,
blue singers.
- Absolutely.
- Like, it doesn't, pop singers.
I lived there for like 12 years.
Like every, it's just a place you can go
if you love music and it's therapeutic.
There's so many shows to see,
so many places and people
to meet, to network with.
It's a really cool, you're
gonna, you're gonna love it.
- Yeah. I'm so excited.
- Yeah. Thank you Charles. (applauds)
- Oh, thank you guys.